I have been recommended the black sand blood root capsule since August of 21 or rectal cancer
I recently had a cheek swab following the surgery indicating that my supplement should
remain the same.
I'm wondering if that still applies to my black sand blood root since my larger testin
is being temporarily bypassed via the Iliostomy, that the blood root may not make it to the
larger testin.
The answer is yes, that still applies.
So you're absorbing, we're not killing directly with the black sand capsule, you're absorbing
most of it before it got to that area.
It's what's in the black sand blood root capsules is blood root which is an herb, raviola,
urnoc, and shaper elder, four different herbs that are really good for cancer, not just
colorectal cancer but really good for different cancers.
So yes, you're absorbing that's going through the bloodstream, it's helping our goal
is that it helps kill cancer cells anywhere, it finds them including anesthetic cells.
So yes, yes, stay on that protocol.